[Music]
all over this narrow
closed strip of land they are again
picking up the pieces
they will again rebuild until the next
time
this is the story of al water street the
main street in gaza city its commercial
heart it was hit hard at one in the
morning
last sunday it's the story of a
grandmother
of a little girl of the families who
were here that night
and what life holds for them now
from a third story window a young girl
peers down at what was once her home
hello she's called susie and her family
those who are left have allowed us in to
meet her
and talk to them
susie's survival is remarkable and it's
clear immediately
that it's had a deep impact
on sunday morning the seven-year-old was
pulled alive from the rubble of her home
[Applause]
her father survived too but her siblings
and her mother did not
the israeli military say they were
trying to hit an underground military
structure
which caused the building to collapse
the 40 people who died here
were unintended casualties they say
samira is susie's grandmother her
guardian now
a woman who has never left gaza and who
has now lost
four grandchildren
across the street at the local bakery
they're back at work
the place is intact but the elderly
owner can't understand
why no warning was given
it is through spontaneous conversations
that you hear the reality of life here
in gaza
we don't live here it's hell
odai bashir had approached us to offer
his thoughts
most of the people he is under the
poverty line
the future in gaza there's no future
no opportunities no jobs just nothing
you live eat sleep
just this you can't do anything
you can get out uh i see the life in
social media
the mountains the explorers
i wish i could i i that's
i wish i could do that
the destruction of al water street is
replicated in pockets across this strip
the experiences of oday are shared all
over
marc stone sky news in gaza